yeah welcome to this game blitz game
against Thomas tell us okay mm-hmm okay
maybe go for Kings Indian again just for
the sake of its nice playing this kind
of thing it's not very exciting okay i'm
allowing efore with trans position to
the to the pills now i wonder if d 5 is
a movie is this a move d 5v5 94 okay
let's not reinvent the wheel here having
spent for 30 years so bit awkward anyway
okay i think i can go here anyway
because of g5 at the end that looks a
lot like some kind of eloquence defense
cap nothing I particularly like this
position Bishop g4 maybe
yeah why not Queen takes okay yeah I can
take e 5 but d5 is also hanging de5 he
might have 95 mm I can check can take
them for a relatively simple pollution
maybe a 97 on e6 i have d 5 yeah maybe
at this rather flexible andy sixx is
kind of tempting but i don't think very
good actually now he can probably he can
probably play that but II 65 is
definitely not a problem for black yes
yeah i mean the structure looks a bit
awkward but i have good chances to maybe
get a 5 plate so that's not so bad
Wow okay that's not exactly a move I
thought would happen okay isn't this
just good for black I mean this is a
good structure for black if he takes d7
now and he kind of has to write so Queen
shakes or is there something even better
probably not yeah that's a very
comfortable structure that looks a
little bit like an exchange Queens
gambit cards but with them with the
awkward bishop them so I'm going to pile
up on the sea pawn with this or with
this I don't know Roxy for probably four
rook c8 and attacking deform just as a
little side note
yeah of course there you can do that but
now his bishop is not anchored will be
kind of awkward after I'm tripling on
the C file which will happen maybe
doubling is actually sufficient I am
interesting does he want to go see for
their but I can't take on the form
okay that's that's that's not a bad move
anyway so Roxy 8 jan i can go Quincy 7
here Roxy wonders bishop age 6
stopppp remove too much but rocks III I
can relatively safely preemies so that's
what you call a week pawn on a half-open
file so what is he doing what is he
going to do some counter play him maybe
yeah it's not so easy to to determinate
them at how I'm actually going to win
this it looks very nice but how to how
to really get somewhere
c2 is all nice and good but I probably
need a second weakness somewhere
because now let's let's not think about
that too long or thinking if he goes
Queenie 5 and takes with the pawn is d43
winning it check maybe is deform king e
1 p-3 and that is winning actually you
form any other move yeah it seems to
seems to be the right one rook takes of
course let's not screw it up oh that I
have forgot about not sure how good it
is but I didn't really think about the
move okay but it's not a big deal rook
TX Roxy wants to wins the problem is not
so in any case so what now look just the
rook checa a check
time warning
yeah 1 know that it's all or pretty good
go check yeah I'm just far too slow it's
not not really necessary to think that
long in this position
chest fortunately not winning looking at
porn and game
not sure why check allowed that I didn't
see that this was attacked stupid stupid
stupid no unnecessary check yeah what a
small chain I really hate that
especially in a completely winning end
game to screw it up like that just
playing for time when you must be joking
check game drawn I'm just an idiot just
a plain idiot yeah I just have to pay
one handed of attention and see that
he's double attacking them just be five
or whatever they all win God yeah this
is a kind of games that keep me from
getting to 25 year where you just check
check just should win and nothing
nothing's happening really that's really
really bad check check I'm just I'm
taking too long also in those simple
positions where I kind of see oh they're
all win what do I play I should just
play one of the moves yeah that was a
pretty nice game actually I should just
win it yeah I getting to this position
is this really nice
like it's just dominating a very very
nice game here against the sea porn the
whole opening sequence was was
interesting the Sun was an interesting
way to play I think you 65 yeah I don't
really understand Bishop takes d5 had
this leads to a clearly the phyria game
for white I thought he has to remove the
bishop somewhere I don't know like here
now then I cheek or maybe a as do it
does he have anything else yeah i don't
know i mean this is it it's just better
to than that because here the bishop is
so misplaced he will get to the indie
game condition and this is just kind of
hotels if you and if you are there d3
i'm just interested in if I could have
done something much better our route c5
is also very strong since this is very
strong yeah that's even better
technically check this wind checks the
other the other thing is even even
clearer 5 and form and cheeks yeah
unfortunately route d3 is not winning
check so I have to do this yeah and I
don't know I don't know why you went g
for them I mean it's probably it doesn't
matter it's both lost but yeah this is
really a stupid move okay I didn't have
much time but still just just this and
and over nothing he really has nothing
here just go like here here and and it
winds itself okay I'm this as much this
is this is costing points yeah if you
want to go to 25 this is some the kind
of game that you really have to win if
they give you everything that you want
you don't take it okay well thanks for
watching